- [Mark] All right Sidra
Sidra where'd you grow up,
where are you from originally?
- I am originally from New Mexico.
- [Mark] Oh, cool.
- Yes.
- [Mark] And tell me about
your family growing up.
You had both your parents?
- Yeah, so I have both my parents
both my parents are still married.
So I had a pretty I guess what you call
a fulsome vanilla childhood.
I grew up in a really small town
you know, small public school.
It was kind of like a
small government town
so everybody that lived there had a parent
that probably worked for one
of the labs or something.
So it was kind of like
a hush hush kind of...
- [Mark] Hmm. Very good childhood?
- Yeah. But really nice childhood.
And I spent most of my
childhood as a dancer.
So I think I started
dancing pre professionally
when I was 10 years old.
So that was kind of
basically from then on out.
That was....
- [Mark] In ballet?
- Yeah ballet and modern, that
was kind of like the focus
that kind of took up
most of my time as a kid.
- [Mark] That's great.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] It's good to
have a focus or a sport
or something like that.
- Yeah. I was really
shy until I was an adult
so that was kind of a good outlet for me
because I was really energetic.
So it just worked out
really well creatively.
- [Mark] And your life
went in what direction
after that?
- So then what happened,
so you know, I was dancing
for most of my life.
I started dancing professionally,
ended up, you know kind of
typical, like millennial.
My parents didn't like
force me to go to college,
but kinda, you know, like you
know, pushed me in a corner
and, you know didn't
want me to be an artist.
So I ended up studying business
while I was still dancing professionally.
And I was living in
Albuquerque at the time
which was a really
interesting place for me
looking back on it now being a sex worker.
Like my time in Albuquerque
was very like anti-sex work
anti-sexual.
I always felt like I
needed to cover myself up
and not be sexually provocative.
Just kinda like based on just
like the area and the region
and dealing with a lot of
just like bad situations
with a lot of like sexually aggressive men
and it's kind of just
the culture out there.
So that really definitely shaped me.
And it's interesting to come into like,
thinking about all of that
and then going into sex work as I'm older
and living on the West
coast in this like free...
- [Mark] Is your personality fairly free
and you're not inhibited?
- Uninhibited. Yeah.
Well, you know, it's kind of funny.
I used to be that way and like very driven
towards just kind of like living for today
and not really thinking about tomorrow.
Ironically again, in
like not what you think
about getting into sex work.
I feel like my trip into
getting into sex work
was actually not within that lifestyle.
You know, I feel like I
almost have a much more
controlled lifestyle and
a much more planned way
of getting into things now
that I'm in sex work
and I'm a little older
and mature about things.
- [Mark] You're fairly
new to the industry right?
- I'm very new yes.
- [Mark] How long you been doing this?
- So I shot my first film this summer.
So let's see, it is December,
so it's been just shy of five months
that I've been in the industry.
- [Mark] So you're pretty much brand new.
- Brand new yeah.
- [Mark] How'd you get
into or how did you decide
or how did you get into it?
- It's really weird so,
you know, it's funny
cause we're still in 2020
and thinking back to myself,
the first three months out of the year
I had a normal nine to five
business job, management job.
I mean, I always thought, you know,
like, oh maybe I'd get a
sugar daddy or something.
I feel like every girl is like, I'm cute
shouldn't I have a rich
old man giving me money?
But never in a million years
thought I'd get into any kind
of sex work, especially mainstream porn
where I'm out on the internet everywhere
for a lot of people to see.
But, you know, I lost my job in March
and was really just worried.
It was taking a long time
for my unemployment checks
to come in and I was
starting to run out of money
and I was really horny.
Like I'm sure a lot of people were.
So I ended up starting camming
because it was just something that like
I kind of have an exhibitionist kink.
So like it kinda just like satisfied that.
And I was like, oh if I could
make a couple extra dollars
too like, why not?
It looks like these girls make money.
And then I ended up kind
of right off the bat
I was making better money than I was
working my 60 hour a week management job.
And it was like, oh wow.
And it also just ended up
being a really nice freeing
experience.
I feel like because the world was over
I was kind of allowing myself
to break free of this wall
of not openly displaying my sexuality.
And I feel like it was
kind of just like a gift
that I've been hiding
from the world for...
- [Mark] So you always had
this exhibitionist in you?
- Absolutely.
Well, just this, you know,
I've always had just a
really big gift of sensuality
that yeah again, I feel
like I've always restricted.
And so anyway, so I got into
camming, took some pictures
got offered a random gig for porn
out of the middle of nowhere
and was like, wait for how much?
Oh that sounds fun.
And then never heard back about that,
but kind of just had the seed planted.
And I think, you know, it's been a while
since I've really been able
to perform, be a performer
and call myself a performer
you know, that being my formal occupation,
even though I've still continued to dance.
So the idea of being able
to be a performer again
was really exciting.
So I ended up reaching out to an agency
and, you know within my first month,
I think I got booked for about nine shoots
and it's been really awesome.
I really opened up sexually
- [Mark] Pretty good experience?
- Well yeah, for the most part
it's been an experience
of trial and error,
but I think what I like most about it
is that nobody else has
control of my future
or my brand, except for myself.
And there's something that's
been really nice about that.
Especially coming from a corporate world
where I had you know,
every kind of limitation
keeping me from doing the
work that I need to do.
So it's just interesting
that a lot of people
look at sex work as something that...
Cause sometimes this sex work
is something that people do
out of necessity.
But for me it was something
that I did out of opportunity
if anything else.
So...Yeah.
- [Mark] So you also had the inclination
to do this kind of work
anyway, your personality?
- Absolutely.
- [Mark] Yeah.
Cause I think a lot of
people, men and women
would get eaten up and
chewed up and spit out.
- Absolutely. Yeah, no,
I mean I think part of it
like I've grown to be very independent
and I spend 99% of my time alone.
So the idea of just being able to go out
and have sex with people for work.
- [Mark] Is it a social life?
- It's yeah.
It's a really nice
additive to a social life.
You know the idea of having
sex with a bunch of people
all the time it keeps
it very simple as well.
Because even if you're dating someone
that's also doing the same thing
that comes with a lot of hurt feelings
I'm sure at the end if the day.
- [Mark] Is this new career
getting in the way of your personal life?
Your romantic life?
- I guess I could say yes,
but like it's kind of non-existent
so that's kind of why I
felt like it was something
really easy to dive into
like just like feet first.
Cause in the personal life that I've had
the past couple of years
I live very strange from my family
like not emotionally personally
but just like physically.
I haven't had a significant
other in a long time.
So if anything it's
helped my personal life
thrive a little bit more.
- [Mark] Are there any
downsides to this career?
It sounds like you're enjoying it.
The money is fairly good.
- Oh yeah, its like fairly good.
The downsides is that
at the end of the day
and I'm still learning this
and I forget this, you know
I came from like a corporate job
where people like...
People find a way to fuck
you over in that way.
But you know, the sex
industry is still a hop, skip
and a jump away from the
hustlers on the street, you know
and so I've just definitely
learned a lot from my mistakes.
- [Mark] How old are you?
- I'm 27.
- [Mark] 27?
- Yes.
You know, when you're selling sex
there's always gonna be
someone that's gonna try
and take advantage of you.
I mean, when you're selling anything
there's always gonna be someone
that's gonna try and
take advantage of you,
but especially sex.
- [Mark] Yeah. I mean,
there's another layer
to what you're giving.
- Absolutely.
- [Mark] You're giving up for money.
Like if I work at a department store,
as that just mentioned to
someone else I interviewed
from your industry, you're
still selling yourself
your time or your energy
or you're whatever,
but with what you're doing,
you're doing that in addition,
you're almost like, I mean
in some ways intimacy, sex
is synonymous with your soul.
- I like that. I was almost gonna say it.
- [Mark] And you're selling that.
- Exactly. Well yeah,
because you're giving
a part of yourself to someone that's...
Again, it's an intimate experience.
It's like, for example, you
know, you don't just go around
(alarm wailing)
- [Mark] That's the neighborhood alarm.
(Sidra chuckles)
- I'm trying to think
like say that you know,
you don't sell your emotional experiences
with everyone or you don't
give those away for free.
It's the same kind of thing.
It's like someone taking
away something very intimate
and special to you for free is different
than someone taking an
object from you for free.
- [Mark] But at least in
your industry, I assume
everyone's doing it in a respectful,
somewhat dignified way, right?
- For the most part.
But again, it definitely
takes a good gut instinct
and I'm really happy that
I came into the industry.
You know, I'm kind of
definitely a lot older
for you know, for a girl
getting into the industry
and having coming from my
past, living in Albuquerque
and dealing with a lot of
sexually aggressive men
sexual abuse and that kind of stuff
really taught me when I
came into this industry
to trust my gut feeling
and know that at the end of the day,
like everyone's kind of methodical.
There was something interesting
that I learned from camming
is that you have, especially
when you're brand new,
you probably have about a hundred guys.
If you're online enough you
have a hundred guys a day
trying to scam you and you
learn patterns and stuff.
- [Mark] To try scam you how?
- Just a bit, you know, like
they try and get a free Skype
show and anything that
they can get out of you
try and get out of you for free.
You know, a lot of guys if
like a girl doesn't know
how to use...
- [Mark] Hold on.
(alarm blaring)
- [Mark] Thank you. Sorry.
- Oh, no worries.
I mean, you know, there's
so many men on the internet
trying to pose as agents,
as experts as this, that,
or the other thing.
(indistinct) amount of money.
And they're very
sophisticated ways of doing it
but you eventually learn patterns.
I'm learning that in person in porn
there's a lot of content shoots now,
which has made porn
very kind of complicated
the porn industry
because you don't have
professional companies
all the time booking you for shoots.
You have another performer
that wants to make content
with you, that you both can
potentially make more money
than on a certain platform.
But what comes with that
is it's just a lot of men
blurring the lines of, oh,
I want to have sex with you
versus I want to make content with you
(alarm blaring)
- [Mark] Something's going on.
- So we'll see how that
continues to complicate
the sex industry.
Because I have already myself,
you know been roughed up
a little too much during a content shoot
and heard, you know
heard numerous stories,
a lot of girls doing the same thing.
And you don't have the kind of protection
of having a full set of a director, PAs
and all of these other people
to make sure that nothing bad
- [Mark] So it's just
like you and some guy?
- A lot of times yeah.
And so I'm interested to
see how like that's gonna...
That's like really interesting part
of the porn industry
that I'm still learning.
- [Mark] Do you find
you need your intuition
to be heightened?
- Exactly.
I would just wonder
about what would happen
had I gotten to this earlier.
You see a lot of girls
that get into bad things
and it's too bad because a
lot of it's just immaturity
or just lack of understanding.
- [Mark] What emotions
does it bring up for you?
I mean, do you get depressed sometimes
or do you get angry or, I mean?
- Yeah, it brings a lot of anger
just because at the end of the day
there's really nothing
that you can do about it.
I guess well, maybe that's
like anger I've always felt.
You know, I dealt with some sexual abuse
when I was in my early twenties
and like domestic abuse
and then, you know at
the 'me too movement'
and then a lot of stuff
came out this summer in porn
and really kind of reshaped
and started a new conversation
in the mainstream porn industry.
But at the end of the day
all I can think is like,
it doesn't really matter.
Like nothing's really gonna change.
So I suppose that emotion
comes from out of frustration
if nothing else.
But I hope that there are
a lot of people out there
that don't feel the
same as I do.(chuckles)
- [Mark] It's a shame
that humans are so mean
to each other.
- It's a shame, but I mean,
if you look at children
and just like the amount
of hate that a child,
you know a child without, you
know, that kind of anxiety
that you learn to get as an adult,
I think it's just in us unlimited.
- [Mark] You don't think learn it
from our families or?
- I don't know.
It's hard to say because maybe...
But kids I think kids
learn it from other kids
- [Mark] Or parents or whatever.
- Parents, but yeah, perhaps.
But yeah I don't know.
I guess I'm just more
of a pessimist (laughs)
I do believe there's
goodness and bad in everyone.
But no, I mean, unfortunately
I just got a Twitter this year
which is the worst
decision I've made in 2020.
And like, you can really see how genuinely
mean people can get.
- [Mark] Yeah. No social media commenting.
- Oh yeah, absolutely.
Especially when you don't have...
- [Mark] Communication is just awful.
- Yeah well..
- [Mark] For the most part
My channel is pretty good,
the majority of my
commenters are very evolved
and compassionate
but there's still the
riffraff, (mumbles) hate.
- But I don't know.
I mean, I think hate
gets kind of addicting.
Because I see it in myself, regularly,
especially during COVID
where I'm locked down at home
and I just have my computer to look at,
I find myself I have to take breaks
because I just like get addicted
to like finding information
to just like feed into that anger.
And I know I'm not the only person.
Exactly.
And I have to take breaks.
- [Mark] I mean, you just use logic
because hate accomplishes
- Nothing.
- [Mark] Nothing.
- Exactly. But you know...
- [Mark] looking positive.
I mean, it'll just bring on more hate
and if that's what you want then sure.
If there's something you hate
and you express yourself
about how awful it is
you're just feeding,
putting fertilizer on.
- Exactly. But it's interesting
how addictive that can be.
And I see that happen in the
industry, in this industry.
- [Mark] So to me, all I see
is it makes me lose sleep
or or stresses me out
so I just turn it off and it's done. Done.
Zero
- You know that's the smart way.
(indistinct)
Yeah you know I mean, we'll see.
I also just moved to Los Angeles too.
So my porn....
(Interviewer chuckles)
- [Mark] You're going through a lot
of transitions there.
- Yes my porn transition is
also coming into Los Angeles
where like I live my life very
based on like natural healing
and stuff.
And being stuck in a giant
bubble with millions and millions
of people is very stressful.
It takes a lot of mental work
to be able to reside here.
I feel it's like, you know
how when you're at the top
of the ocean, there's
the waves crashing down
and they're really loud
and crazy and heavy
and then you go about 10 feet below
and everything's nice and calm and still.
I mentally have to put
myself there every day
to live in Los Angeles.
Where this is Los Angeles is the surface.
And you know we're living in
a very, very hateful time too.
- [Mark] Yes we are. That's a shame.
- That's a big shame.
- [Mark] Well Sidra I
wish you the best of luck
with your new career.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] You seem fairly
well suited to doing it.
- Yeah we'll see.
- [Mark] I just hope that
those little horror stories
you're experiencing don't continue.
- [Sidra] Yeah. We'll see.
You know, and I hope they don't continue
for other people in the industry.
I hope that sex work can
eventually become something
that is seen as positive
and not something that needs
to be brushed under the rug.
- [Mark] Yeah. I'm not
sure what the answer is.
- We'll see, we are in America,
so I'm not sure if there is an answer.
- [Mark] That's right.
All right, Sidra, thank
you so much for coming in
and talking.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] Good luck. Thanks.
That was fun.
- [Sidra] Cool. Yeah.
- [Mark] Fun little chat.
- [Sidra] I used to get off on tangents.
- [Mark] Yeah. It's kind of cool
when somebody is intelligent
enough to be able to do that.
Which you are obviously.